ja das war jetzt nicht so herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video wir
spielen heute wieder eine neue und zwar
haben wir heute die map feind debatten
unexpected am start da geht es darum
dass man in jedem level den knopf finden
muss um das nächste level zu erreichen
aber man findet sie in unexpected das
heißt in unerwarteten seltsamen
komischen um die verrückten hasen beißen
die map ist also relativ neues man dies
vom 15 06 jeden fall legen wir jetzt los
ließ google mail user namens cluster n
joy ok alles klar
jetzt brauchte button den ernst
wtf was war das denn
wie sind wir jetzt hier hoch gekommen
wie seit unerwartet vielleicht für ideen
wie das passiert ist dann könnte es
einen kommentar schreiben
ich bin einfach wie immer der absolute
minecraft noob und review juli potatoes
es eilig da schiebt sich irgendwas hin
und her
wenn wir aus stunden einstellen button
batten barton brüstungen button
ok
sehr schön alles kleiner weil er mich da
oben in der wand die waltons austricksen
wollte mich austricksen
ich glaube verboten aber dass wir eine
schule waren also hört auf eurem leben
zu verdrängen mit magic alles klar
hier nächstes level habe ich diese
gefühle liebe hat ich glaube nicht egal
okay das sieht doch mal hier nach aus
denn ist schon erwarten 90 und als ob
das ist wie super sieger single geöffnet
okay wir jetzt schon mal das trocken das
war es auch gerade eben wie so ist
dieses ding erschienen
die überhaupt keine ahnung wie sagte
tirano was das war
und ich hab den worten viele viele
buttons ist einfach nüchtern
ja ja ja ja also dass keiner von denen
ist also bis jetzt keiner von denen ist
was zur hölle schicken stunden später
alles klar was von der menge buttons
aber das war nicht die basis schon mal
hier rein
okay da muss nicht
mit der kartoffel was macht nein das ist
jetzt nicht so hilfreich
2000 jahre später gewinnt leute sind
blogs surfen was junge junge junge
da ist ja das ist wirklich ein experte
das ist meist gemacht das ist echt mies
gemacht
wir drücken dem warten auf den nächsten
level
als ob das gleiche jetzt noch mal wieder
nichts abbauen
wir sind irgendwie unsichtbare blöcke
als ob es das ist was als ob das der
knopf weshalb ich gesehen wie zb drauf
gelaufen sind irgendwie blöcke einfach
treppen und sichtbare treppen und als ob
das jetzt hier um den knopf ist das
glaube ich nicht
ich glaube ich nicht leute das kann sich
sein weil es ist wirklich der knopf die
kaffee ok ok alles klar
wetten dass ist wieder genauso hier
mitmischen und beim blocken darauf weist
die ecke ab
die schönheiten hetzern wie geht's dem
programm auch dabei oder vom leben
welches leben das leben sondern
ich wähle ich diese lösung sein die sich
die ganze zeit ins holt aber der raum
sieht für mich ziemlich ziemlich leer
aus und herzlich willkommen zu einer
thronfolge minecraft ist der knopf
vielleicht einfach hier oben und muss
einfach nur gut drauf einfach
hochspringen dass sie aber auch zu
risiko okay dass man hin
ja
das weiß nicht so
als also wie ich verstanden dass ich
gerade einfach der knopf nachdem ihn
aber als hilft benutzt haben
in steve verwandelt ok sigrid messe
potatoes realistisches highway you know
me erinnert ihr euch eine botschaft von
den kartoffeln jahren habe ich nicht
mehr so genau und die kartoffel
botschaft welche seit deswegen k
ja und jetzt also für rausgeschmissen
wurden dass es ja mega sie 2000 klare
sportliche for you know me also weiter
ist es nicht dass andere dem später
wunderbar getötet zurückgeworfen bei
unseren sport muss man sich dazu aus wär
ja delicious werden kartoffeln sagen
dass sie selbst den löschen sind dann
würden sie eigentlich das würde dazu
führen dass sie gegessen werden von
anderen leute ist es das schloss in
eurem leben darüber nachzudenken was
kartoffeln anderer stelle machen will
deswegen gucken jetzt einfach darum
fucking heißt wir haben die alter was
ist dass man die besten potatoes
babysitters eckhard hoppe vom gesicht
wie wir mal was es ist diese map
eigentlich das war scheinbar das ende
von feind debatten unexpected relativ
kurz und knackig eigentlich genauso wie
ich mag welches gefallen hat dann
schreibt kommentare wenn ihr mehr davon
wollte übrigens schreibe meine
kommentare wir generell zu finden wenn
ich zum abspiel und das bisschen mehr
zusammen hatte wirklich passieren
bis dahin hat rein macht gut und ja